what is the secret to a lasting romance
well bachelor Ben Higgins and his
fiancee Lauren Bushnell are simply
trying to figure that out they have a
new reality show and they're already in
therapy
et on lives lauren zima visited the
couple in denver at the restaurant acorn
the spot of their first date I think
it's some point look at each other said
I actually really love you
like I really do love you and I'm glad
that we're doing this together and I'm
glad that year alongside me of this
you're really the first couple to get a
show of their own after the bachelor and
what will people be surprised to see in
this show what will they learn about you
guys everyone saw our fairytale but I
think they'll learn that we are not
perfect
ready what do you mean I'm a choice feel
like you just said yes for both of us
but this just isn't like my idea of fun
you just not told me this to be
completely honest like it has been a
struggle at times for us the first
challenge adjusting to living together
Lauren left her life in LA to move into
Ben's bachelor pad in Denver
we know a new city making new friends
that was really hard for me and going
through all those changes they turned to
counseling to get through it
you're our church we were doing couples
counseling way before even premarital
counseling couples therapy we need kind
of an arm like a mediator between us
just to help us communicate any things
that we you know need to work out
individually together and then let's
celebrate
you know like Lauren makes my life
better mr. Chris Harrison I just talked
to him he told me he wants to officiate
your wedding is there a date no there's
not there's no date hopefully next year
could we see a televised wedding from
you guys I mean I think it's a cool
opportunity and we've invited everybody
into our life at this point why not you
know let them continue and you're gonna
have cameras at your weddings anyways so
why not add you know the whole
production